ونذكر مشاهدينا بهذه الاخبار العاجله
نشاهد على شاشه العربيه الان اداره
الكوارث التركيه تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد
ضحايا الزلزال الى
قتيلا
وواحد بل احدى 21 الفا ومئه وثلاثه اصابات
حتى هذه اللحظه
سنكون معكم اذا مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه
الاحصائيات التي تتغير بصوره متتابعه حسب
حالات الانقاذ التي تجري الان سواء في
تركيا او في سوريا اليونيسيف الان تتحدث
عن ان زلزال تركيا وسوريا ربما تسبب في
قتل الاف الاطفال
وما زالت حتى الان مشاهدينا عمليه الانقاذ
المستمره كما نشاهد في هذه الصور بحثا عن
ناجين بين انقاض الاف المباني التي انهارت
بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال
غرب سوريا نلاحظ في هذه الصور المباشره
الان عمليات الانقاذ سواء من سوريا او من
تركيا الحصيه الاجماليه مشاهدينا لعدد
القتلى في البلدين تجاوزت خمسه الاف بعد
هزات ارضيه عنيفه ضربت مناطق قريبه من
الحدود التركيه السوريه بلغت قوتها 7
درجات فاصله ثمانيه